c'est agressif sont un type de leucémie
assez agressif il ya trois ans mathieu
données girouard a reçu un diagnostic de
leucémie lymphoblastique aiguë ce soir
plus avancé plus les traitements de
chimiothérapie fonctionnait pas les
options diminué pronostic n'était pas
très en ma faveur
on lui propose un traitement
expérimental développé entièrement au
québec une greffe de cellules souches
modifiées en laboratoire l'avaline à
perdre donc pourquoi pas laisser ces
l'hématologue guy sauvageau et son
équipe qui ont développé cette technique
on s'en va dans ce qu'on appelle la
thérapie cellulaire c'est à dire un
traitement un traitement qui est un peu
plus compliqué mais ensuite le patient
et sans traitement pour le reste de ses
jours après des années de travail les
chercheurs ont découvert une molécule
uem 171 qui permet de multiplier par 30
lycées le sujet qu'on retrouve dans le
sang de cordon ombilical
c'est un pote g1 le sang de cordon est
le meilleur réservoir de cellules
souches pour traiter les cancers du sein
et celui qui cause le moindre rejet mais
il contient trop peu de cellules pour
traiter un patient adulte avec l'effet
multiplicateur de uem 171
on pourra donc entre été beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui à peine 5 % des patients
reçoivent une greffe de sang de cordon
avec uem 171
on espère un greffé dix fois plus testé
depuis 2005 chez l'humain le traitement
accomplit des miracles ce qu'ils eurent
réussi coeur des patients cook avait
déjà échoué une première greffe qu'on a
emmené dans l'étude et la grande
majorité de ces patients là n'ont pas
récidivé et on est maintenant à plus de
30 mois de suivi dans l'étude depuis le
début de l'essai clinique il n'y a eu
aucun cas de rejet
aucun cas de maladies immunes et un seul
patient sur 22 est décédé on a aussi
observé que le traitement régis neyret
d'autres cellules souches du corps
humain il ya même des évidences que
certaines cellules cérébrales sont
reconstitués par
sous populations cellulaires amplifié
par la molécule donc oui on commence à
penser aussi à des maladies
neurodégénératives qui pourrait
peut-être répondre à ça pour mathieu
données girouard la thérapie a rempli
ses promesses après une longue bataille
il est prête à retourner au travail ça
va super bien
même aujourd'hui on les instruments pour
pouvoir mesurer ce qu'ils appellent la
maladie résiduelle
puis on est capable d'avoir que j'ai
zéro maladie résiduelle
le lieu est rien c'est vraiment comme si
j'avais absolument rien la phase finale
de l'essai clinique de uem 171 débutera
bientôt au canada en europe et aux états
unis
il sait normand grondin radio canada
montréal